el 15 de enero trae cambios en el pase
de salud en francia a partir del sábado
es necesaria una dosis de refuerzo para
que sea válido en bares cafés gimnasios
cines sitios turísticos y trenes de
larga distancia si una persona recibió
la segunda dosis hace más de siete meses
y no ha recibido una tercera desde
entonces el pase será inútil esto se
aplicará a cualquier persona mayor de 18
años los niños de 12 a 17 años pueden
continuar usando sus pases sin tener el
refuerzo el pase de salud es desde ahora
crucial para la vida cotidiana se
necesita un pase de salud para todo y
cualquier cosa sin él no podemos vivir
hacemos lo que tenemos que hacer para
tener algún tipo de vida social según el
ministro de salud más de medio millón de
personas están en riesgo de que esos
documentos sean desactivados estos
cambios se producen cuando el gobierno
busca convertir el pase de salud en un
pase de vacunas más estricto la
madrugada del sábado se aprobó el
proyecto de ley en la asamblea nacional
en una sesión que comenzó a las 3 de la
tarde del viernes y concluyó a las 4 de
la mañana del sábado se hicieron casi
450 enmiendas
185 otros a favor 69 en contra y 8
abstenciones
el cambio principal sería que las
pruebas negativas de ccoo y 19 ya no
servirán excepto para el acceso a las
instalaciones y servicios de salud las
propuestas también sugieren sanciones
más severas por fraude la presentación
de una tarjeta falsa puede ser
sancionada con cinco años de prisión y
una multa de 75 mil euros el proyecto de
ley se retrasó varias veces porque los
senadores y los asambleístas no lograron
llegar a una conclusión el proyecto
continuará siendo debatido en el senado
el sábado